this show has closely followed the
possibility there could be unknown
entities in the skies above us I believe
that but could there be even closer than
that right here a new Wall Street
Journal report profiles the many parents
who think they can see ghosts specters
and mysterious movements on their
advanced baby monitors that means a baby
is there some parents describe blurry
humanoid figures others say they see
floating white orbs Brett Larson is a
host for fox news headlines 24/7 he
joins us what's the deal it's an
interesting one right as more of us put
cameras in our homes we're catching some
unusual events and some think they're
seeing electronic devices are catching a
glimpse of something supernatural take a
look at this image from a Kakuna cam
baby monitor the colors are there to
indicate movement but the family using
that device noted their baby was
sleeping peacefully in the bassinet and
nothing was moving but was something
paranormal watching their sleeping baby
and look at this a nest user in Brooklyn
New York was alerted to movement in
their child's room when they checked the
video they found the closet door was
open but neither parent opened the door
on a replay they see the door eerily
open itself but was it paranormal no
actually you can clearly see something
fell inside the closet knocking open the
door that turned out to be a blanket and
one camera manufacturer said the most
likely explanation is dust particles
curtains moving simply some light
reflections causing the cameras
technology to go a bit haywire one
manufacturer even suggested the camera
was installed incorrectly leading to the
unusual images that some users don't
accept those explanations some think
it's more like loved ones who have died
keeping a watchful eye on their home and
their newborn a paranormal investigator
suggested installing a second camera to
see if the images are captured on both
devices that I actually have a camera
that watches over my dog and sometimes
when it switches to night vision you do
see the dust particles and they do look
a little ominous I think there's an
explanation you know you're a classic
skeptic and that's fine I think it could
be a little bit of both but but thank
you great story